lo que se escuche ópera clásica pero no
está sonando aquí dentro en el magnífico
teatro colón de buenos aires que está
cerrado desde el inicio de la cuarentena
el 20 de marzo pasado aunque sí son las
voces de sus artistas que encontraron
otra forma de llegar a su público en
este contexto de pandemia
no
todo
son piezas en vídeo de óperas clásicas
que se pusieron a disposición del
público en el sitio web del teatro se
grabaron en la casa de los cantantes
solo con lo que ellos tenían a mano a mí
lo que me pasó fue sentirme un poco de
nuevo en mi infancia jugando a macgyver
pero a pesar de ser caseras son súper
producciones que llevan cada una hasta
más de 100 horas de grabación y en las
que a la distancia aportan su
conocimiento todas las áreas del teatro
la elección de las obras tuvo mucho que
ver con el contexto actual
por ejemplo el ajaccio pianga surge a
partir de una charla que tuvimos en el
medio de un ensayo donde uno de los
cantantes aseguró que todos habíamos
orado en el transcurso de la cuarentena
por lo menos una vez y nadie pudo
negarlo
i
el proyecto le permitió también al
teatro colon abrirse a nuevos públicos
tiene un porcentaje muy alto muy alto
está siendo visto y disfrutado por
personas que nunca vinieron al color con
la cuarentena en el teatro descubrieron
una nueva forma de montar las óperas de
siempre y no la van a abandonar así que
continuarán produciendo estas piezas y
distribuyéndolas en su sitio web por
ahora desde las casas de los artistas
pero apenas puedan lo harán desde un
estudio dentro del propio teatro colon